[Música]
hola kilómetros que pasan deprisa como
decíamos la percepción del tiempo podría
ser como el paradigma de schrödinger
porque hay gente a la que el tiempo se
nos pasa muy rápido muy despacio y
conforme nos vamos haciendo mayores el
tiempo va pasando todavía más rápido por
eso hay que aprovechar mucho el tiempo
esta señora era mi abuela vivía nació y
vivió en un lugar pobre de hace de la
españa pobre a 40 kilómetros del mar y
nunca vio el mar no pudo nunca hacer un
viaje de 40 kilómetros para ver el mar
ese señor muy culto todos y todas le
conocéis kant vivió y nació en una
ciudad que hoy es nació y vivió en
alemania en una ciudad que hoy es rusia
y su mayor viaje fue de 150 kilómetros
tampoco viajo mucho
cuando el tren se generaliza en 1820 la
gente pensaba que se le iban a
desintegrar los pulmones debido a la
velocidad que cogía el tren y la verdad
es que la velocidad eran de 40 o 50
kilómetros por hora tampoco mucho pero
en estos viajes repensando desde la
comodidad en lo que ha supuesto
desplazarnos uno se da cuenta de que
hicieron falta miles de años para
conseguir superar la velocidad al galope
de un caballo es decir desde que aparece
la escritura por ejemplo hace cinco mil
años hasta que conseguimos superar la
velocidad del galope de un caballo cinco
mil años y por eso la gente pensaba que
los pulmones se iban a desintegrar
luego llegarían los barcos de acero los
trasatlánticos para poder llegar a otros
continentes y hoy en día se puede viajar
lento pero con gran comodidad pero esta
es la fecha clave la fecha mágica que lo
cambia todo a partir de ese año en
europa comienza a liberalizarse lo que
es el espacio aéreo y los precios de los
billetes de avión comienzan a bajar
bastante a partir de esa fecha es cuándo
la movilidad se democratiza y cuando
todos y todas podemos acceder a viajar a
movernos
es muy curioso que tardemos lo mismo en
tren hoy en llegar de madrid algo que en
regresar de nueva york a madrid o que un
billete de avión de madrid a miami pueda
costar lo mismo que un billete de avión
de madrid a la coruña por tanto son
asignaturas pendientes pero si el mundo
sigue avanzando en ese sentido
llegaremos al paradigma al paradigma de
schrödinger de poder estar en dos
lugares al mismo tiempo
y decíamos antes que cuando vamos
envejeciendo el tiempo comienza a pasar
más rápido y si uno o una lo que hace es
quedarse en casa pues ese tiempo que
está pasando muy rápido no lo vamos a
aprovechar y por tanto hay que
plantearse qué queremos hacer con
nuestro tiempo si queremos viajar muchos
kilómetros y si la nueva moneda será el
tiempo poder decidir cómo gastar nuestro
tiempo y no repetir el tiempo en estar
siempre en el mismo lugar
esto es un gasoducto ya existe
un gasoducto se puede construir pues por
muchas partes del planeta
esto que se parece al gasoducto es un
tubo
si se logra conseguir el vacío en ese
tubo que parece que se podría conseguir
podríamos meter una cápsula y
desplazarla a más de 1000 kilómetros por
hora con unas comodidades tremendas
ese soy yo dando clase y yo con unas
vacas si el tubo anterior de vacío
funcionará yo podría estar a 600 o 700
kilómetros de aquí por la tarde con las
vacas y por la mañana dando clase y no
es un escenario de ciencia ficción es
algo que podría ocurrir que podría
suceder y además este tubo podría ser la
solución a la catástrofe a la catástrofe
demográfica de muchos territorios de
españa y de otras partes del mundo hay
muchísimas localidades y muchísimas
provincias que se están quejando de la
falta de población igual llevando un
tubo y conectando lugares que están a
500 600 kilómetros a 20 minutos de
madrid pues la gente nos planteamos
vivir en otros en otros sitios a mí me
gustaría vivir en mondoñedo ya hemos
citado al mundo antes en este télex a mí
me gustaría estar por las mañanas en
madrid meterme en el tubo por las tardes
y en 20 minutos estar en mondoñedo estar
con las vacas y al día siguiente volver
a el tubo 20 minutos y volver a
madrid bueno ya hay mucha gente que se
está planteando este tipo de escenario
pero la cosa cambia estos son
televisiones pasamos del blanco y negro
al color
lo llamaban la caja tonta ahora ya la
televisión no la utilizamos para ver
cosas que no aporten cultura o sí pero
también para ver cultura y también para
trasladarnos yo perfectamente podría ver
la evolución de los sistemas actuales de
televisión de cómo del full hd estamos
pasando al 45 cayó choca y si llegamos
al 16 que es prácticamente la vista
humana es decir si yo tuviera aquí ahora
mismo una televisión en 16 acá
probablemente yo no sabía si estoy
viendo la televisión o ese estudio es
estoy viendo a vosotros y vosotras en
directo fijaos lo que supone esto para
el cerebro porque hasta ahora para
viajar tenía que llevar mi cerebro y mi
cerebro tirar del cuerpo y una vez mi
cerebro tira del cuerpo con todo lo que
eso supone porque los cuerpos humanos
son subóptimos se cansan cogen frío se
acatarán engordan se atontan quieren
echarse la siesta y hoy me planteaba
enviar aquí a mi avatar y quedarme
echándole la siesta al final mi avatar
no funcionó bien y he venido yo pero
estamos muy cerca con esto del 8 acá
si yo esta tecnología del 8 acá la
integró en unas gafas de realidad
virtual pues estamos muy cerca de poder
viajar sin desplazarnos y lo más
gracioso de todas estas tecnologías es
que yo ahora cuando acabe mi charla me
voy a poner mis gafas y me voy a ir a
mondoñedo y yo con esto podría trabajar
pero lo más gracioso de todo esto es que
muy probablemente cuando todo esto
llegue y estamos hablando de 5 o 10 años
igual el trabajo ha dejado de existir
muchas gracias y buenos días
[Aplausos]